vous deviendrez des experts de votre corps.
Vous deviendrez une autorité.
Ce n'est pas difficile.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir un doctorat en statistiques
pour être votre propre expert.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'un diplôme en médecine
pour être l'expert de votre corps.
Les médecins sont les spécialistes de la population,
mais vous êtes votre propre expert.
Aussi quand les deux se rencontrent,
quand les deux experts se rencontrent,
vous deux êtes en mesure de prendre une meilleure décision
que votre médecin tout seul.
A présent que vous avez compris le pouvoir des informations
que vous tirez de votre propre collecte de données,
j'aimerais que vous vous mettiez debout et que vous leviez votre main droite.
(Rires)
Oui, levez-vous !
Je vous mets au défi
de vous approprier vos données.
Et, en ce jour, je vous confère
un diplôme TEDx en statistiques élémentaires
avec une spécialisation en analyse en fonction du temps
avec tous les droits et privilèges y afférant.
Ainsi, la prochaine fois que vous irez chez votre médecin
en tant que statisticiens initiés,
quelle devra toujours être votre réponse ?
Public : « Montrez-moi les données ! » T. Williams : « Je ne vous entends pas ! »
Public : « Montrez-moi les données ! »
T.W : « Encore une fois ! »
T.W. : « Montrez-moi les données ! »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)